and with just days left before
Republicans regained control of the
house house Democrats released six years
worth of former president Donald Trump's
tax returns the nearly 6 000 pages of
documents cap off a years-long battle
between the former president and
Congress Scott McFarland reports from
Washington
six years of former president Trump's
tax returns reveal he paid 750 in
federal income tax in 2016 and 2017 and
nothing in 2020 claiming more business
losses than earnings how is he in a
position to pay so little some years
less than you and me in income taxes
it's a great question look the tax code
is is extremely complicated president
Trump has utilized the tax code to his
Advantage Democrats went all the way to
the Supreme Court to get their hands on
the returns after Trump defied Decades
of tradition declining to release them
voluntarily as a candidate then as
president Democrats publicly posted the
documents four days before they lose
control of the U.S House the power of
the presidency is so great and so unique
we need to make sure that that person
regardless of party is above reproach
the returns also show zero charitable
donations listed in 2020 despite Trump's
pledge to donate his four hundred
thousand dollar a year presidential
salary to charity so we can't tell if he
was telling the truth when he said he
was donating a salary or not but again
upon IRS audit they would ask for those
kinds of documentation from the tax
preparer but Democrats say the returns
revealed Trump wasn't audited by the IRS
as he'd claimed and as it was expected
of the IRS during much of the presidency
Trump in a recorded statement called the
release a political attack the seizure
of these confidential records was
completely unconstitutional there is no
legitimate legislative purpose for their
action
and if you look at what they've done
it's so sad for our country
Republicans on the house Ways and Means
Committee were also critical of the
release of the tax returns and they take
control of the panel as Republicans take
control of the house Tuesday with the
new Congress for CBS Saturday morning
I'm Scott McFarland in Washington